le point presse presque terminée c'est
d'une manière assez cocasse que paul
magnette leader du parti socialiste
annonce qu alexander de croo sera le
nouveau premier ministre belge
un peu d'humour pour marquer la fin
d'une crise politique de 493 jours
alexander de croo ancien vice président
du conseil et ministre des finances dans
le gouvernement précédent est membre du
parti libéral flamand open vld
il dispose désormais de quelques heures
pour constituer son équipe sous le signe
de la coalition dite vivaldi cet esprit
là
cet esprit des travailler ensemble cet
esprit de trouver les solutions
c'est ce que j'ai ressenti autour de la
table aussi dans cet accord qu'il a
conclu avec les sept partis
on va avoir besoin de tout le monde pour
de nouveau faire fonctionner notre
société pour faire fonctionner notre
pays de nouveau pour répondre aux
attentes que la population à deux nous
l'accorder cette partie est baptisé
vivaldi en référence aux quatre saisons
du compositeur elles correspondent aux
couleurs des quatre familles politiques
présentes dans cette alliance au sein de
cette coalition on retrouve les deux
partis socialiste le ps et le sp.a les
deux partis libéraux
l'open vld et le mouvement réformateur
les écologistes des partis écolo et
groen et enfin les chrétiens-démocrates
du cd&v ensemble il dispose de la
majorité au parlement fédéral
avec 87 des 150 sièges
je ne pourrais pas vous dire à quel
point ce matin c'est un profond
soulagement
c'est un moment que nous attendons tous
depuis 16 mois maintenant 16 mois d'une
crise trop profonde
trop longue qui a profondément abîmée la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans la
politique cela ne devrait être qu'une
formalité mais le parlement doit
accorder sa confiance au gouvernement
nommé par le nouveau premier ministre
l'ensemble des mines
str prêteront serment ce jeudi matin le
vote de confiance du parlement pourrait
quant à lui avoir lieu samedi